[Aplausos]
olá boa noite a todos então fui
convidado para falar um pouco seu prêmio
à minha área da tatuagem fico feliz por
estar aqui hoje e espero que no final da
manhã explique o pessoal sinto inspirado
a fazer uma tatuagem e principalmente
aquele que está iniciando na área o
pretendido já trabalha é se inspire mais
ainda mas eu não posso falar de tatuagem
agora se voltar um pouco no tempo onde
eu me meu contato com a tatuagem como
surgiu
é eu sempre tive uma facilidade desde
criança em fazer desenho é da minha
época na década de 80 a 90 não tinha
internet não tinha tv por assinatura não
tinha um monte de coisa mas tinha papel
caneta em casa e eu me lembro de por
muitas horas passar na frente de um
qualquer aparelho objeto dentro de casa
e e desenhar fazer aquele aparelho
o mais legal de tudo além de fazer o
desenho é mostrar o meu pai e minha mãe
melhorar o desenho e meu filho legal
continua e de uma certa maneira que não
foi um incentivo para continuar fazendo
porque é legal ficar ouvindo da família
um elogio no planeta depois de criar um
desenho
isso foi por um bom período até na pré
escola na parte do ensino médio
e parou por um período quando começou na
parte do procurar emprego
eu tenho a sua profissão então isso
ficou de lado por algum tempo por alguns
anos devemos assim quando eu decidir meu
último emprego foi de metalúrgico
trabalhava numa fábrica de pedais aqui
da cidade e por muitas horas eu pensava
que não era aquilo pra mim que eu tinha
que fazer alguma coisa que eu tinha que
aquilo não ia dar certo não podia ficar
minha vida inteira lá naquela fábrica e
surgiu uma por uma ideia uma luz de
fazer algo relacionado à desenho que eu
já fazia que já tinha uma certa
habilidade só que comecei a fazer então
que não chamava na época de e hoje ainda
a hidrografia comecei fazendo pintura do
capacete tanque de moto é capô do
veículo
capitu celular o que tinha de de objeto
que pudesse botar tinta e fazer desenho
era o que eu fazia ea minha mãe é ela
foi ela gostava muito disso e chegou pra
mim um dia e disse aquilo que você não
faz tatuagem principal em tatuagem não
eu não tinha contato algum com tatuagem
com gente tatuada na época você tem uma
idéia e eles não é tatuagem mas ela
gostava muito e meu pai era muito
preconceituoso com esse tipo de coisa na
época e eu acredito que foi a maneira
dela me levar a tatuagem que ela gostava
tatuagem também né e de uma certa
maneira deu certo
eu lembro de muita insistência dela
pedir o encontro porque não compra o kit
compra vai atrás vai atrás procura
alguma coisa que você começar a iniciar
a fazer tatuagem aí pro pesquisando na
internet onde eu podia comprar algum
tipo de material encontrei lá o que
dizem de internet pronto lá prático
máquina tinta e acabei comprando
pois bem agora comprei o material tenha
tinta tem uma máquina e como é que vão
fazer
como é que se aprende a tatuar não tinha
ninguém pra ensinar os que tinham na
cidade eram tão cabeça fechada que
chegou a perguntar uma dica que eles
mandavam vazar porque não quero sair
muito difícil aqui não vai conseguir
fazer então para tom aquilo de uma certa
maneira quando a pessoa faz isso com
você você se se põe polis não vou
mostrar pra você que eu vou conseguir
nada e não viu outra alternativa me
lembro que eu fui comprar no açougue e
um pernil de de porco la e divulgá lo
mantido aquele pedacinho nem só de pele
pra mim favor mas só até não é só tem aí
ele veio pra cá todo feliz né caso vamos
inaugurar essas máquinas e potência da
mesa e que não sabia nem como é que
montava sei que não há quem me conhece
tatuagem tem a borrachinha e pai eu me
lembro que eu tatuei um bom tempo sem
botar aquela borracha que não seja
vencer a dinamarca acabou hoje
e depois vem o pele de porco era legal
etapa quando tem uma base mas a pele
pouco não gritava perna de porco não não
gemia de dor ela não chorava e também
não reclamar civil que desenhe ficasse
ruim né
então eu tinha que sair perde porque pau
e como não fazer
a mãe foi a incentivadora ela diz não
vou fazer uma quem já passou fácil pelo
pescoço e
começamos nela daí ela já falou com a
amiga dela daqui a pouco volta e meia
alguém batia lá em casa batia na porta
para fazer uma tatuagem
então onde está então vamos abrir uma
loja
vamos fazer um estudo a virtude de fazer
as coisas certinhas abrir a primeira
loja ea minha trajetória de carreira eu
dividiria em três partes
essa seria minha primeira parte até a
primeira loja studio que eu dei um
título assim é fazer tatuagem
eu não era tatuador fazer a tatuagem que
é bem diferente
então o que era é que a gente chega a
perder um desenho sem lá que normalmente
não achava um desenho em papel internet
e desenhos prontos havia copiado de moto
tatuagem uma revista se pegava a revista
tinha um desenho da tatuagem que não
tinha qualquer desenho aqui nessa pegada
tirava fazia só que era muito difícil na
época e eu me lembro que o meu sonho é
conseguir fazer uma tatuagem por dia
era meu sonho eu fazia uma por semana eu
me lembro que eu já era casado ea minha
esposa por uns dois anos praticamente
ela que manteve a casa né porque não
ganhava nem por comida diz assim pensei
em desistir
eu me lembro de tentar estudar para
concurso público e fazer bico do meu pai
que a oficina do meu pai porque eu
estava vendo que não tinha mais condição
de seguir com isso
mas aí a gente não podia desistir vamos
insistir mais um pouco e surgiu a
oportunidade de abrir uma outra loja
mais comercial no centro
então eu conseguir fazer essa mudança de
ponto vamos dizer assim e com a
freqüência de clientes vindo mais porque
tinha um ponto comercial era o acesso ao
pessoal verão mas era mais fácil que
passava na rua vi a placa subir
comecei a fazer uma tatuagem um dia sim
outro também
e às vezes a gente tem que cuidar com o
que a gente pede
e daqui a pouco já estava tatuando uma
por dia e duas por dia e três por dia e
daqui a pouco estava 10 por dia
ele que eu estava ficando louco tipo não
conseguia mais é era muita demanda e não
dava conta minha agenda para conseguir
morar comigo ea gente espera pelo menos
quatro meses três meses para conseguir
um horário
atuando todo dia é todos os clientes
mais ou menos eu aprendi com meu pai
assim muito responsável com questão de
horário
então você nunca vai me atrasar lugar
nenhum eu sempre vou chegar dez minutos
antes ou até antes disso então era muito
chato com o horário que a gente chegasse
dez minutos atrasado já estava virando
barra estava explodindo por que aquilo
ia me atrasar dez no outro e no final do
dia e ter que ficar lá até que horas da
noite para poder compensar eu também não
gosto de deixar o cliente esperando e
essa demanda toda é de clientes e
forçavam a não ter um horário pré
determinado para eu começar por mês para
começar a tinha não tinha pra acabar
começava de manhã ao abrir uma loja
noite e meia e vez vejo outro que ficará
feliz quando chegar em casa às dez da
noite
normalmente chegava depois disso a
família a esposa era muito difícil
porque eu não conseguia dizer não
trabalhava sozinho no estúdio a minha
irmã na época mesma colocava pici
então eu tinha que eu tinha que
administrar a loja pagar a conta comprar
material atender cliente fazer tatuagem
agendar e volte me batia clientes lá no
mesmo horário olhava os dois de kaká que
está fazendo aqui
assim marcou eu ia ver o tinha marcado
os dois no mesmo horário e final de
semana a mesma coisa passava muito tempo
durante o dia trabalhando e chegava o
cliente dizer a palavra não posso
durante a semana que eu tenho faculdade
eu estou na noite em que você tava lá em
um sábado de tarde fazendo às vezes a
pessoa trabalha no comércio para o
comércio o sábado 20 trabalha junto só
posso o cara domingo a domingo de manhã
atuando só que daí isso começou a me dar
um colapso teve que fazer tratamento
psicológico para poder me resolver a
minha situação não poder atender bem o
cliente também porque tava sempre uma
pilha de nervos com a demanda e com o
tempo eu tive a oportunidade de conhecer
uma pessoa que me deu um alerta né
no período assim que eu passei
praticamente com essa loja nova assim
foi mais ou menos uns cinco anos fazendo
a festa do dia então já me considerava
um segundo parte da minha da fase de um
profissional me considerava um tatuador
e não vai ser um profissional da
tatuagem e eu me lembro de alguns
clientes chegarem quando estava tatuando
olhava pra mim assim dizia para si só
torna você trabalha comigo é só faz
tatuagem está muito paga suas contas em
casa como é que é
não eu tenho a minha casa agora enquanto
pagar aluguel
então tá tipo próprio cliente achava que
eu não consegui vir dever da tatuagem na
época inclusive eu às vezes
então esse esse período assim de fazer a
tatuagem do dia tratamento no ritmo de
tatuagem não na parte psicológica como
dizer assim fazia acreditar que era um
cara bom de tatuagem e chegou um amigo
de scarpa se evite fazer uma
especialização agora começou uma fase
pessoal fazer o choque é um artista que
vem lá ele faz como é que uma tatuagem
para você olhar e você tira conhecimento
troca idéias eu pensava comigo cara que
eu vou lá ver um cara tá tomando já faça
parte do dia o tempo ele vai lá me
ensinar segurar a máquina montada a
borrachinha agora já sei que não preciso
e deu que ele chegou para mim ficar mais
e vai vai ser bom pra ti não é muito
caro não se equivoque lapa florianópolis
fazê lo assim que seja o teu nome de
você lá você vai se você não gostar não
precisa pagar então eu fui
fui com toda a vontade assim mas o kit